Transcriber: Yara Hosam
المدقّق: Marina Naguib
قبل خمس سنين من اليوم، كنت طالبة بالصف
الثاني عشر، كنت مثل كل الطلاب حائرة بين
أين سأدرس وماذا سأدرس، وماذا سأفعل
في المستقبل،
وما ستكون خطوتي القادمة.
وفي يوم من الأيام أحد أصدقاء العائلة حدثني
عن تجربته والمغامرة التي عاشها
أثناء الدراسة بالخارج،
وكيف كانت وما الأشياء التي واجهها،
وما التحديات التي خاضها
وكيف تمكن من التغلب عليها،
وعن كل المغامرات والثمرات
التي حصل عليها في النهاية.
وفي ذلك اليوم، عدت للبيت وفكرت
فقد كان هذا اليوم بالنسبة لي
نقطة تحول في حياتي بأكملها.
وفي اليوم التالي، تحدثت مع أهلي
عن الفكرة وناقشناها
وحاولنا نفكر في كل المحاور التي تخصها
وكانت مشاعرنا متضاربة بين أنني أريد
خوض هذه التجربة
وأريد تجربتها ورؤية الثمرات
التي من ممكن أن أجنيها
وكيف يمكن أن تؤثر علي شخصيتي وتبنيها،
وبين أنه لا، كيف يمكن أن أذهب بمفردي
وما هي الصعوبات التي ستواجهني
هل سأتمكن من تخطيها أم لن أتمكن من تخطيها،
ولكن في النهاية جمعت كل الأفكار الإيجابية
وركزت على الإيجابي،
وجمعت كل شجاعتي التي أملكها وأخذت القرار
بأنني سأدرس بالخارج بعيدًا عن أهلي
في بلد لم أزروها من قبل
ولم أذهب إليها من قبل وفقط سمعت عنها.
إذًا لماذا يخاف الناس دائمًا من الفكرة؟
يخاف الأهل خصوصًا من فكرة الدراسة بالخارج
وأيضًا يخاف الطلاب من الإعتماد
على أنفسهم مئة بالمئة
وأن يكونوا مسؤولين عن أنفسهم وعن كل
المشاكل والصعوبات التي ممكن أن تواجههم.
ففي وجهة نظري السبب هو الخوف من المواجهة
وخوف من الصعوبات وخوف من الأفكار السلبية؛
لأن هذه الأفكار دائمًا تتركز
في أدمغتنا ونركز عليها،
ونتجاهل الثمرات التي من الممكن
جنيها في النهاية
ونتجاهل هذه التجربة وكيف يمكن
أن تؤثر على شخصية الطالب،
وكيف يمكن أن تنميها وتعزز فيه الكثير
من القيم والمهارات والمعرفة
والمعلومات التي لن يتمكن من جنيهم
في البيئة التي يعيش فيها
بدون الاختلاط مع البيئات الأخرى
ومع مختلف الجنسيات،
فلماذا تستحق المخاطرة؟
لماذا تستحق الدراسة بالخارج
المخاطرة والمجازفة؟
أولاً، الدراسة بالخارج تسمح للطالب
بتوسع دولي مهم جدًا،
أما بالنسبة للمستقبل الوظيفي
فستسمح له بالتعرف على علومٍ جديدة
واختصاصاتٍ جديدة ليس على دراية بها
أو غير متوفرة في المكان الذي يدرس فيه.
فبالنسبة لي، كان اهتمامي أن أدخل
اختصاصات طبية أو طب بشكل عام
ولكن بعدما ذهبت للخارج ودرست بالخارج،
أكتشفت أن هناك اختصاصات أخرى
مشابهة لما أطمح له
مشابهة للأحلام التي كنت أحلم بها،
لكن ليس شرطًا أن تكون طب فقط
فتسمح لتوسع الآفاق عند الطالب.
حاليًا في زمننا الحالي، يحب الطلاب
دائمًا أن يكونوا
من جميع أنحاء العالم مع بعض في تواصل
والدراسة بالخارج تسمح بذلك أيضًا،
الطالب اليوم يحب أن يكون دائمًا
على نفس النحو وعلى نفس المنهج
مع الطلاب في كل أنحاء العالم،
يحب أن يكون لديه توسع في التكنولوجيا
وفي التطور،
والتعرف على الثقافات والتعرف على اللغات
والتعرف على المجتمعات الخارجية
والدراسة بالخارج تسمح له بكل هذه الأشياء.
وفي النهاية، بالسنوات الدراسية الأخيرة
أو بعد أن ينهي أربع أو خمس سنين من دراسته
سيعود بتغير كامل في شخصيته وبالمعرفة
والمهارات التي يمتلكها
بسبب التعرف على الآخرين.
وهذا الشيء بالمقابل أيضًا سيسمح
للطالب بالتعرف على نفسه
بالتعرف على نفسه من الداخل؛
بسبب الأوقات التي سيمر بها وهو وحيد،
ستسمح له بالتعرف على ما يحب وما لا يحب
وما هي الطاقات الإبداعية التي يمتلكها؛
فهو سيكون قادرًا على إظهارها.
ما هي الأشياء التي يُبدع فيها،
وماذا بالظبط سيحبه الطالب
وما لن يحبه.
ستسمح له أيضًا من خلال التعرف على
ثقافات أخرى في المجتمع
وسلوكيات تطور في المجتمع الذي يعيش فيه
بنقل هذه الأشياء الجيدة
إلى المجتمع الذي كان يعيش فيه
أو إلى بلده الأم.
فبالنسبة لي كطالبة في المجال الطبي
وفي الرعاية الصحية
بعد إكمالي للدراسة عدت لبلدي الأم
وحاولت أن أبني شركة صغيرة
حتى أنقل الذي تعلمته هناك لبلدي الأم
ولكنه شيء ليس بالسهل ولم يحدث بيومٍ وليلة،
ولكنني في النهاية حاولت
ونقلت تقريبًا الأشياء التي عرفتها هناك
لبلدي الأم في سبيل التطور.
أكيد وبدون شك سيمر الطالب بأيام صعبة
أيام يشعر فيها بالغربة ويشعر فيها بالوحدة،
ولكن بالنهاية هذه الأشياء كلها
ستنعكس عليه إيجابيًا
وستجعله إنسانًا مستعدًا للتطور،
إنسانًا مستعدًا لتنمية مهاراته
إنسانًا مستعدًا لتقبل الآخر، وهو مهم جدًا
أن يتقبل أي شخص يقابله،
سيكون مستعدًا ليخوض تجارب
الحياة الأصعب من الدراسة.
في النهاية بعد خمس سنين من الدراسة بالخارج
بالنسبة لي، عدت الحمدلله مع شهادة ماستر
في علوم الأجنة وأطفال الأنابيب وعلاج العقم
بالإضافة إلى الكثير من المهارات
التي تعلمتها،
والكثير من الأشياء التي طورتها بنفسي،
حتى شعرت أنني اليوم قادرة على
مواجهة الكثير من الصعوبات
التي يمكن أن تواجهني في مجال العمل
أو في مجال الحياة الإجتماعية
أو في مجالات الحياة الأخرى أيضًا.
فإذا أنت اليوم طالب أو أنتِ اليوم طالبة
وتستمعون لهذا الحوار
ولديكم فرصة لخوض هذه التجربة،
لا تفكروا في الصعوبات
ولا في الأشياء الصعبة التي من الممكن
أن تواجهكم، لكن خوضوها
خوضوا التجربة وجربوها
حتى ولو كانت سنة واحدة فقط،
ستكون بوادرها إيجابية عليكم
وستنمي فيكم مواهب ومهارات
لن تستطيعوا اكتشافها مطلقًا.